We always call APAC as a region as being on the rocket ship...
...because we have just started our journey...
...that's truly one percent done.
If you look at the way technology is evolving,...
...I think there is a massive opportunity...
...to get the rest of like, the 2, 3, 4, 5 billion people, online.
We've got a front seat with a window...
...in that this is where a lot of the growth is actually happening.
The single largest region in the world for Facebook is Asia-Pacific.
At Facebook, we have the mission to give power to people...
...and make the world more open connected.
And the reason we think about it as a mission is...
...because we commit and deliver value not only to who we work with...
...but also to people outside of Facebook across the world.
One of the things I love about working on Facebook is that...
...we are a mission-led company.
It's a very exciting time to be in this region for Facebook...
...because there's so much growth potential, so much opportunity to be filled.
If you wanna work in an environment that you have a strong sense of ownership,...
...you get to work with a bunch of elite, smart people on high-impact projects...
...that have a massive impact on billions of people, then this is the place to work.